québécois indépendant.
De Maître sont avec moi. Bonsoi,
ça vs s dit comme expert donc la
preuve que des données faisaiens
eue beaucoup de doute sur laveve
Marie-Pierre Boulay d'abord.
rapidité ça peut faire en sorte
que rapidement, ça peut vouloir
dire qu'il y a peu de libération
que les jurys s'entendent
rapidement sur la manière de
donner les résultats d'par
exemple.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il fallait qu'il
décide c'était quoi la question
essentielle? Je vais résumer en
termes de lancement, lequel des
deux je crois?
- En fait c'est surtout pas ce
qu'il faut faire. Parce que ce
crédibilité. Les termes
juridiques. Est-ce qu'il croyait
ou non laccusé. Je ne le
pas, est-ce que sa version
soulève un doute raisonnable et
preuve incluant le témoignageeee
est faite hors de toute doute
raisonnable. C'est un
raisonnement en lelelelelelelela
expliquées avant de les
délaisser délibéré.
- En deux mots ils ont cru la
victime, ils n'ont pas cru
Haro p p p p p p p p p p p p p e
raisonnable dans l'esprit
tititititif du jury. Ce n'était
pas un cause très complexe. On
parle d'une soirée quelquemomoms
extrêmement complexe. Ça
explique la rapidité. On regarde
que ça me satisfait hors de taux
de raisonnable. De la dépense à
chercher à traquer sa
crédibilité, semble avoir été
c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c .
- Dans beaucoup d'autre causeise
était le consentement. Les gens
disaient elle voulait que ce
n'est pas vrai que ça été uneeuu
tout à ça. Lui il a dit ce n'es?
- Devient une affaire de
n'est pas comme si il y a
s'est passé mais je revendique
une croyance sincère au
consentement. Elle dit ne pas
avoir consenti des éléments qui
parce qu'elle est confrontée.Let
que ma collègue a bien résumé,
la formule juridique pas
complexe qnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
verdict. N'est pas celui de
doute raisonnable et le
témoignage de Madame étai
complet.
- Témoignage de Madame étéititià
redonner confiance aux victimes,
justice. Personne n'était là
dans la pièce, c'est risqué.
Mais on atatatatatatatat clair
et nette dans ce cas-ci.
peut comprendre que ce n'est pan
de notre propre caererererereret
Monsieur Lebel de ce côté
craindre d'être lui-même le sest
pas une question de force du
nombre, c'est une question de
fi
emploie dans le domaine po
voir qu'est-ce qui est retenu
comme preuve.
- Vous n'êtes pa
qu'il y a tout un débat depuis
des mois et des années sur la
perception du système de justice
certainement contribuer à dire
beaucoup de femmes : c'estpopope
preuve dans tous les processus
que si quelqu'un fait une
dénonciation, il y a un
On est suivi traverse processus
et après salafistes suivra son
cour
été cru les allégations et e
a été créée. Au final chaque cas
encadrement si quelqu'un veut
porter plainte. Traverse le
processus en étend accompagné.
- Dans un autre cas d'espèce, ut
envisager un appel aussi très
dur dans les circonstances
rapidement.drdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrt
plus difficile dans un certain
sens parce que le jury de ne pas
ne l'a pas cru Monsieur Lebel ea
plaignante. C'est là que c'est
plus complexe car ce n'était
deva
retenus pour favoriser l'une
eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeea
précédé le jury
que les directives étaienttatatr
les parties étaient conformes.
C'est plus circonscrit comme
question.
- Vous êtes d'accord? d d d d dn
jours. Après une étape et la
détermination de la peine. On
verra que sur les
respectives devant le juge.
Est-ce qu'il v m m m m m m m m n
crime comme ça?
- C'est possible, la